CBS News legal analyst Ricky Kleman is
with us good morning good morning how
likely do you think it is that a judge
will grant the motion for this expedited
discovery I think that expedited
discovery is the bigger question than
whether or not ultimately the president
gets deposed because I think the
president may well get to pose at some
point expedited discovery the question
is why do we need it so fast is there
something happening out there that we
have to know this within a hundred and
twenty days which is what you might
usually think of he has been asking he
says he wants 21 days for each
deposition very short notice 90 days he
wants the entire thing to go to a jury
trial that is not happening that fast
but why can it last six months or one
year judge what do you police say that's
fine but what do you think of it's this
motion on its face and how did we get
here that we're now in a conversation
about the president the United States
being deposed what do I think of the
motion first the first of all the
amended complaint it's been a long time
since Monday when we talked about the
original complaint the amended complaint
filed on Monday afternoon followed by
this filing in the early morning hours
these are stellar filings they are based
in fact they are based in law they are
based in precedent if a judge in the
federal court judge Otero has this case
goes through this particular amended
complaint and the memorandum and sees
what the president is I got to give you
this one the Restatement of contracts
that's the basic rules of all of
contract law the first example that is
given about voiding a contract is that a
candidate for political office who has
previously written some letters and
taken a contrary position and then wants
someone else wants to publish these
letters and the candidate goes to pay
for them to stop them from being
published that's the example that the
bargain is illegal how did we get here
could this have all been avoided yes it
could creep out really bitter word I lay
all of this at the feet of Michael Cohen
from the very beginning my lawyer
bad lawyering and bad fixing yeah
Michael Cohen is no Michael Clayton so
when you go back to the movie curettage
yes it was very good yeah very very good
yeah George Clooney George Clooney yeah
but there it was a bad fix when you
first start when you go in terms of the
lawyer once he starts making public
statements and he does allegedly defame
her by not knowing her first statement
as truth or falsity he then gives
Michael avenatti an avenue to get a jury
trial which wasn't there before and
damages so now Michael avenatti who has
an endgame he has damages he's looking
for for stormy Daniels
he wasn't looking for that Ricky could
Michael Cohen try to dissolve the NBA at
this point to present prevent a possible
deposition and trial well I think that
what Michael Cohen would have to do is
settle this case now the easiest way you
can't just dissolve it and say I didn't
mean it it doesn't matter and stormy
Daniels gives back the money which he
has offered to do what you have to do
now is have a settlement which is what
you asked him in the last hour and he
had the right answer on Monday is it on
Monday I asked you whether the president
being deposed in 60 days could happen
you said it was an exaggeration what do
you think now I still think it's an
exaggeration but only on the timing only
I'm because you're going to a hearing on
April 30th no then there's going to be
motions and then there's going to be
another hearing so I'm gonna get past my
60 days okay thanks very much Ricky